en este vídeo vamos a en un par de
ejemplos relacionados con rectas
paralelas y perpendiculares tenemos
entonces que las rectas pueden ser
paralelas y perpendiculares y por
supuesto hay rectas que entre sí no son
ni paralelas y perpendiculares la manera
de revisión recordemos que las rectas
paralelas nunca se intersecta dibujemos
aquí unos ejes si estos son mis ejes
coordinados este es mi eje x y este es
mi eje y si inicialmente tenemos una
recta como esta en magenta voy a dibujar
una recta paralela el aquí estas dos
rectas son diferentes pero al ser
paralelas tienen la misma pendiente si
esta recta se mueve en x una cierta
cantidad y tiene esta razón de cambio de
ye con respecto a x esta recta de acá
abajo va a tener la misma razón de
cambio de ye con respecto a x por eso
nunca se intersecta así es que tienen la
misma
misma pendiente las rectas paralelas
tienen la misma pendiente las rectas
perpendiculares bajo cierta perspectiva
son lo contrario si ésta es una recta
dada una recta perpendicular no tan solo
intersecta esa recta sino que lo hace
formando un ángulo recto este ángulo de
aquí es un ángulo de 90 grados ahora no
lo voy a probar aquí lo voy a hacer en
la sección de álgebra lineal pero se
puede probar que si dos rectas son
perpendiculares pongamos que esta recta
tiene una pendiente de m
entonces la recta perpendicular la recta
perpendicular a una recta con pendiente
m va a tener una pendiente que es igual
a menos 1 entre m estas dos pendientes
son recíprocas y de signo contrario bien
ahora conociendo esto veamos algunas
rectas para determinar si son paralelas
y perpendiculares a ninguna de las dos
para lo cual tendremos que checar las
pendientes
una recta pasa por los puntos 4 menos 3
y menos 80 otra recta otra recta pasa
por los puntos menos 1 coma -1 y -2 6
calculemos las pendientes de estas dos
rectas haré primero está en color rosa
entonces la pendiente es la primera
recta que voy a llamar pendiente 1 va a
ser igual voy a tomar este como el punto
final entonces sería menos 3 - 0
el avance en que menos 3 - 0 sobre 4
- menos 84 menos 8 esto va a ser igual
- 3 - 3 - 3 y 4 - menos 8 es 48 que es
igual a 12 y esto es igual a menos
cuarto dividimos entre 3 numerador y
denominador para obtener menos un cuarto
ser la pendiente de la primera recta
calculemos la pendiente de la segunda
recta entonces la pendiente 2 es igual
vamos a tomar este como el punto final
sería menos 1 menos 6 menos 16 entre
menos uno menos menos 2 - 1 - menos 2
esto es igual a menos 1 menos 6 es igual
a menos 7 y el denominador es menos 1 +
2 - por menos es más menos 1 + 2 es
igual a 1 está pendiente es entonces
menos 7 comparando las pendientes ahora
vemos que no son iguales por lo cual no
son paralelas las rectas y tampoco son
recíprocas de signo contrario así es que
no son ni paralelas y perpendiculares es
decir ninguna de las dos las dos rectas
se intersectan pero no van a formar un
ángulo de 90 grados en la intersección
hagamos un par de ejemplos más
aquí tenemos
nueva cuenta una recta que pasa por
estos puntos y otra recta que pasa por
estos otros puntos encontremos sus
pendientes tenemos entonces que la
pendiente de la recta en verde le voy a
amar m1 la pendiente de la recta en
verde cm1 va a ser voy a tomar este como
punto final entonces sería el avance en
ya que sería menos 2 menos 14 entre para
esta coordenada en que éste la equis que
le corresponde 1 - menos 3 esto es igual
al menos 2 menos 14 es igual a menos 16
y 1 - menos 3 es igual a 13 que es igual
a 4 esto es igual a menos 4 ahora para
la segunda recta la pendiente 2 que le
voy a llamar m2 es igual el avance y que
sería 5 menos menos 35 menos -3 dividido
entre el avance en x que es menos 2
menos
- 20 esto es igual 5
353 que es igual a 8 dividido entre
menos 20 que es igual a menos 28 entre
menos 2 es igual a menos 4 así es que
las dos pendientes son iguales y esta
recta son paralelas estás rectas son
paralelas tienen pendientes iguales te
invito a que encuentres la ecuación de
las dos rectas gráficas las rectas y
puedas verificar visualmente que las
rectas son paralelas hagamos ahora este
ejemplo y de nueva cuenta es un ejemplo
en el cual tenemos que calcular
pendientes calculemos la pendiente de
esta recta le vamos a llamar la
pendiente de la recta 1 m 1 veamos
entonces el avance que sería 3 - menos 3
3 - menos 3 dividido entre 3 - menos 6
esto es igual a 33 igual a 6 dividido
entre 36 igual a 96 novenos o dos
tercios
veamos ahora la pendiente de la segunda
recta y la pendiente de la segunda recta
que denominaremos m2 es igual a en el
avance nye que sería menos 8 menos 4
dividido entre 2 - menos 62 menos menos
6 esto es igual menos 8 - 4 - 12 / / 26
- por menos es más esto es igual a 268
entonces está pendiente es menos 12
octavos o simplificando esto es igual a
menos tres medios no tenemos entonces
que estás pendientes tienen signo
contrario y sus valores son recíprocos
veamos esto si hacemos menos 1 entre dos
tercios esto es igual a menos 1 que
multiplica a 3 medios y esto es igual a
menos 3 medios estos dos números son de
signo contrario y son recíprocos si
agarras un número le cambia es el signo
inviertes numerado y denominador
obtienes el otro número
así es que estas rectas son
perpendiculares perpendiculares y
nuevamente te invito a que encuentre las
ecuaciones de las rectas ya tienes aquí
las pendientes las gráficas y verifique
es visualmente que las rectas son
perpendiculares hagamos uno más
encuentra la ecuación de la recta
perpendicular a ye igual menos dos
quintos de x menos tres que pasa por el
punto 28 entonces lo primero que nos
dicen es que es perpendicular a esta
recta y esto qué quiere decir si es
perpendicular esta recta la pendiente
tiene que ser el recíproco de menos dos
quintos con signo contrario así es que
la pendiente de la recta perpendicular
tiene que ser lo voy a hacer con otro
color si es perpendicular a esta recta
su pendiente tiene que ser el recíproco
menos dos quintos con signo contrario
así es que el recíproco de dos quintos
es cinco medios y en vez de ser negativa
va a ser positiva así es que esto es el
recíproco de signo contrario de menos
dos quintos de acuerdo cambias el signo
negativo se hace positivo e intercambia
dos quintos y obtienes cinco medios así
es que este tiene que ser el valor de la
pendiente y ahora para obtener la
ecuación de la recta ya conocemos la
pendiente y sabemos que pasa por este
punto usemos la forma punto pendiente
entonces la ecuación sería de menos 8
este punto tiene que estar en la recta y
la coordenada en ese punto es 8 y menos
8 es igual a la pendiente que cinco
medios que multiplica a x menos 2 que es
la coordenada en x cuando lleva al 8 y
está la ecuación de la recta en forma
punto pendiente si la queremos en forma
pendiente ordenada tenemos que hacer
algunas manipulaciones algebraicas
entonces que tenemos del lado izquierdo
de 100 menos 8 y del lado derecho vamos
a distribuir este 5 medios sería
entonces 5 medios de x menos 5 medios
por 2 los 12 se cancelan y nos queda 5
ahora sumando 8 ambos lados de la
ecuación nos resulta y es igual a 5
medios de x
8 5 es igual a 3 tenemos ya la ecuación
de la recta y así hemos concluido